the initial sort of like a web to web3
kind of thing was all essentially VC
scams
um and you know it was essentially a 16
Zed and Company trying to own the next
version of the web so it was not really
decentralized it just had new owners
um and uh you know Bitcoin happened
right about over a decade ago now and
Bitcoin is freedom money right and you
can't really do anything without Freedom
money uh you can't even build a
decentralized like internet or
communication without Freedom money
because otherwise you can't really do
anything
um even pay for the servers
um so
did uh that you know it was about two
years ago now will uh when he came out
uh is they created this incredibly
simple protocol
that uh that that is very good at
relaying information
and and being sort of like is like
distributed decentralized and it can
also be private uh he lives in all
spaces uh it's incredibly hard to kill
uh it sort of like resolves this problem
so you can have decentralized money and
decentralized communication so that
humans can sort of trade in peace right
uh there is no owners there's no company
uh same for Bitcoin same for an Oster
um this this two sort of this at least
how I see it the combination of the two
uh really sort of like came uh uh had
the Stars aligned uh for us to to build
a more free future for everybody
so will you you along with Fiat Jeff as
nvk uh mentioned there are one of the
protocol developers what was your
motivation for doing this and then we
can discuss a little further exactly
what it is we're talking about but first
I just want to know you know what is
what is the vision here
yeah I've always been interested in like
you know new and interesting protocols
you know Bitcoin really caught my eye
early on and you know I've always been
looking at trying to think of the ways
of getting back to like the early days
of the internet when everyone just it
wasn't like owned by corporations and
people just hung out and had fun
um and you know it was much more
decentralized back then because it was
much more focus on protocols so I've
always been interested in like how do
you apply you know protocols like do you
improve freedom on the internet
um so you know the first one I tried was
Mastodon and Mastodon was like this
really cool idea where you could you
know spin up an instance
um and then join it and then hang out
with your friends
um but that we we started to see that
that um started there's a lot of cracks
in that design in the sense that any one
of those instance admins becomes like
their own little
um like they can just ban you and then
you have to start over so as I was
always looking for a way to like make
this kind of solve that issue where
um like that we have on Mastodon and
then eventually found Nostra and it got
me really intrigued it was really simple
and I just kind of dived in and and you
know and it's been amazing since then so
there was you know a uh and a kind of
Exodus after Elon took over that that
seemed to be the big alternative and uh
some recent articles have shown a bit of
a drop off in recent months
um I I would like to hear from from you
will and and maybe nvk you know what it
is uh that is that differentiates Noster
from something like Mastodon there's
there's a huge flaw in the sense that
you join an instance so I think nvk ran
Bitcoin hackers it was like the only
instance that I was able to get on and
without because I I signed up to like
multiple different instances and I would
just say the word Bitcoin and there's
just so many Communists on that these
platforms I just instantly get kicked
off and I get banned so I have to start
over and build my follower list again so
I'm like I found a home at Bitcoin
hackers uh but then the issue was you
know every other instance just banned
Bitcoin hackers it was really just you
know we only had our small community we
opened bitcoinhackers.org just to in
case Twitter sort of started kicking off
kicking out bitcoiners uh this was while
back I can't remember what was the
reason but there was something that was
going on I think a lot of bitcoiners
were getting Shadow banned on Twitter uh
because Twitter was being run by commies
right and
um so we all started like you know
joining master and I'm like okay maybe
maybe this instance is like how we
finally sort of like Get Enough people a
critical mass outside of Twitter uh as
at least a backup uh
and uh you know my my instance had no no
moderation right I'm like listen you
guys are all adults please don't do
criminal things you know talk about
whatever you want
um and that caused the whole Mastodon
Universe to just block my instance like
so essentially every single Mastodon
server out there blocked it
um um and we had no communication with
the outside that you first thing
um and then I realized like oh wait
there's also people joining my instance
who I actually really dislike and I
don't want to host their data so I went
and I deleted one of them and I was like
okay great I don't want to be benevolent
dictator either right like this is not a
row of want I don't want to holster data
um so uh when I learn about Noster it
was like a little bit too early and and
you know these guys were playing that I
was too busy with Bitcoin
um and then I think it came back a few
months ago I was like okay holy crap
like this thing is really sort of like
now the clients work Wheels it was like
this is great I was pulling up this uh
the Snowden tweets Snowden is I would
say probably one of if not the highest
profile user of Noster at this point you
know maybe Jack Dorsey
um but he describes uh this difference
between a platform and a protocol and
everyone involved with Noster is very uh
you know insistent that this is a
protocol not a platform
um he says a pla if a platform is a silo
a protocol is a river no one owns it and
everyone is free to swim is that an
accurate characterization
yeah I think I think he really hits the
nail in the head in that sense it's like
you know platforms they they control the
data they they Define who's allowed to
access the data at what time and and if
you get kicked out then you can't you
know it's a side load and you can't get
to it but you know in this case it's
more of like a river where anyone kind
of jump in the river swim down everyone
can kind of be involved um so I really
like that analogy
um but yeah it's definitely more of a
protocol than any than a platform so can
I ask real quick uh just follow up with
the metaphor of the river and I'm
thinking now of like you know the lazy
river at uh at an amusement park
everybody's kind of floating along in
their inner tubes how does Noster work
as a protocol to make sure that like
things you know there aren't too many
people you know clogging everything up
uh Etc
and yeah so this is actually a big issue
um because you know I run probably one
of the biggest relays on the domus relay
and it's wide open to the public and
it's just getting spammed to hell
um so it's like that's just that's the
analogy there's like everyone's kind of
clogged and crammed in and you look at
the global feed it's just like spam spam
um so that's a big issue and when one
way you can get around this is a paid
relays um so there's a bunch of paid
relays where you just have 10 000
Satoshi entry fee and it just you know
and then kind of wait like and only
people with those keys can actually post
on the relay so that's one way to kind
of clear up the congestion so the web is
a great is that is a great platform and
I don't know we're kind of you know
abusing terms here but you know people
started to build silos on top of this
like landscape which is the web so the
web is is decentralized you anyone can
spin up a server
um but the kind of the main issue is
that
you know how do these like silos talk to
each other right so if you set up like
Gmail or YouTube or all these different
platforms that you know they're all
independent so yeah in theory like the
underlying substrates decentralized but
the things we're building in this
landscape are not and they don't talk to
each other
um so when I think of decentralization
or at least like the redecentralization
of the web I see like how do we connect
these silos together and how do we make
all these apps that we're building
interoperable so I think Master is like
one of the the one of these protocols
that can actually link these you know
disparate silos togethers which is
pretty fascinating I mean the client is
kind of like Outlook used to be or
something like it it's a lot it allows
you to pull your email into like
supporting that form that you can
organize Etc I do like female analogy
though in that because yeah because the
email is a protocol right yeah so the
email is vertical so the main difference
is so it's a really good analogy because
you can have multiple different clients
so there's a Gmail client there's other
client things like that um so Thomas
would be one client but the difference
between email and Nostra is that you
know in some sense the information is a
siled within it's kind of hard to like
you know you know pull down your data
and push it to another email server so
um that's kind of the main difference is
that the data is much more flexible can
flow much better but it's very similar
to analogy I think part of voluntary
Association is that people can shut down
like they can choose not to associate
with certain people yeah I mean yeah
yeah just just get off the relay or or
you know don't like block people on your
own personal client you just can't
prevent them from Talking hey thanks for
watching that excerpt from our
conversation with nvk and will casarin
about nostrip and the future of the
decentralized web check out the full
interview in the description below and
tune in every Thursday at 1pm Eastern to
catch these conversations Live And
subscribe to recent TV and hit the
notifications Bell to find out anytime
our videos go live